[Music]
okay so this is my spoiler free review
of season 1 of servant the new project
by m9 Shalem on on appletv plus so
they're going to release the first three
episodes to the public and I have only
seen the first three as a member of the
press so basically from these first
three episodes what you gotta expect
here is a lot of people were turned off
by the trailer because they had this
doll baby and you're like okay is this a
whole show based off this baby do we
have to get a on board about it just
being a doll and I'm here to tell you it
is not what you're thinking it isn't the
basis of the show it being a doll baby
so don't let that turn you off from
watching it there is so much more here
than the eye can see in that trailer
that they're not showing you and it is
very strong in the sense of it's a small
cast focused on character writing so you
have so far three of the characters I
think are written really well Rupert
grints character who you meet I think is
the weakest and I have problem with the
dialogue they wrote for him it's an odd
character but the rest I think are solid
the mysteries here they lay two solid
ones on you right away they get right to
it and there's little ones going on
there's a lot of dialogue you have to
pay attention to and it's classic Sean
LeMond where you have the spooky violins
spooky camera angles he directs the
first episode so you'll really feel it
there and he's overseeing this whole
thing thing so you just hope that it's
such good setup and shallow mine's great
at setup but you know in early in his
career he was great at sticking the
landing and recently not so much so he's
lost a lot of people's trust but I think
what makes this interesting and worth
just at least again I always say a trial
of Apple TV Plus for seven days give it
a shot what makes it worth it I think is
that if you are an M night fan it's the
first time we're seeing him really like
put a lot of effort and connection and
really make you feel like shamah in a
whole TV series so it's like okay this
is different now instead of seeing him
doing a full movie like he always does
maybe this is a better format for him
and letting a whole mystery unravel
slower here and kind of make it a more
complicated and again having more time
to flush your characters and it just
it's just more of trusting and hoping
that he sticks the landing so I think
it's something that you'll get enticed
by to give it a shot and it has a great
cast
you got Rupert Grint here aka Ron
Weasley you got Nell Tiger free who is
actually from Game of Thrones who was
Circe's daughter who got killed and she
is great as the sitter and you have Toby
kebbel here from Black Mirror who is
awesome he's in a bunch of movies as
well and Lauren Ambrose from Six Feet
Under
it's one of those shows that if you like
just the vibe of Rosemary's Baby the
movie you like this show there's a lot
of inspiration from it clearly and again
if you like good mystery I think it's
worth it in that alone and I think
that's what's cool about the mystery
genre is you can still enjoy a lot of it
in the sense of sometimes it doesn't
come through at the end but mystery
keeps you hooked and there's no doubt
about it that Shawn man is good at that
and he's really good at it here and it
is the main focus in this story but it
does not let characters go to the
wayside it focuses on them and I think
that's just a benefit of it being a
small cast so it does a hell of a job on
that and it's probably if you think
you're into this type of thing you're
gonna like this if it's a show you're
not into this type of thing you're not
gonna like this just I saw so many
people turn off by the doll thing just
trust me
get past that it's not what you think it
is it's not committed to that there's so
much more there so again I'm not trying
to spoil anything but I highly suggest
this I'm giving the first three episodes
and season one as a whole right now
because we've only seen the first three
is a 8.3 but that can go away higher as
episodes get dropped week by week and of
course I'll be reviewing every episode
of this show and I'll have a spoiler
review up on the show drops of the first
year episode so make sure to subscribe
you don't miss one of my reviews as a
servant I also do Watchmen at the moment
and I do His Dark Materials and I also
do celebrity interviews so you don't
miss that and please follow me at Steve
Varley 1 on Twitter squared for more of
me
and please please leave your comments
below if you're interested in the show
if you're gonna watch it just your
thoughts and as a whole I'd love to hear
it and I'll
see you next time